a move to impeach new york governor
andrew cuomo over allegations of
repeated sexual harassment could start
as soon as next week
and a lawyer for his former aide lindsey
boylan says
she plans to sue cuomo and people in his
administration
investigators found the governor
retaliated against boylan who was the
first to come forward with misconduct
claims
our national correspondent jerica duncan
has covered this story four months
streak a lot of people are wondering now
what about criminal charges
exactly and that's the big question
right now we have four district
attorneys including here in manhattan
that have now launched probes into
alleged sexual harassment of at least 11
women detailed in the state attorney
general's report
while the bar is high criminal charges
could be possible
civil cases now seem very likely
when lindsay came forward the flood
gates open
attorney jill basinger represents
governor cuomo's former staffer lindsey
boylan
the first woman to publicly accuse the
governor of sexual misconduct
boylan first came forward via twitter in
december
in the state attorney general's report
she says the governor sexually harassed
her
physically touched her including on the
waist legs and back
kissed her on the cheeks and on one
occasion on the lips
now that the report is out does lindsay
fear retribution today
yes she absolutely does according to the
report
after boylan came forward the governor
and the executive chamber actively
engaged in an effort
to discredit her including by
disseminating to the press confidential
internal documents
that painted her in a negative light and
pending a never published op-ed
going after her credibility lindsay
plans to sue the governor for
retaliation
why not go after the governor for the
sexual harassment piece
the governor can deny sexual harassment
even though
he shouldn't the governor can say
nothing about the retaliation
there are emails there are witnesses and
the retaliation is also honestly
the worst part of it because it just
it completely discourages other women
from coming forward in an 85 page
response released tuesday
governor cuomo denied he sexually
harassed boylen
and questioned her motivations i want
you to know directly from me
that i never touched anyone
inappropriately
or made inappropriate sexual advances
do you think the governor will resign
before the end of the week he should
but you know i i don't know if he will
he's taken a very strong position of
i didn't do it and he's basically
calling everyone else a liar
people familiar with the situation tell
cbs news there's an
understanding among legislators that if
cuomo does not resign by the end of the
weekend they'll move quickly to impeach
a source with cbs news tells us that the
governor has no intention of resigning
and his plan guys right now is really
uh to keep quiet and stay out of the
news but that's almost impossible
because you have
um these alleged victims that continue
to come forward to tell their stories
now that it's been
public and corroborated yeah he's not
talking but everybody else
exactly and the legal action is just
beginning jerica thank you